while many sitcoms stars have gone on to
continue in many films and tv shows
others have decided to move on with
their lives though we'll always remember
them for their roles here are the real
reasons you don't hear from these
sitcoms stars anymore
ross bagley appeared in the final two
seasons of fresh prince of bel air as
nikki the youngest son of the bank's
family though he was the smallest member
of the cast he left a strong impact be
it mocking uncle phil's age or just
goofing around with will he also spent
time with will smith the actor outside
of bel air on the set of independence
day as his son since then he's mostly
stayed away from hollywood is he another
child star burnout nope he's living a
normal life in california doing normal
things after leaving acting he grew up
and went to college at california state
university northridge he's been working
as a realtor in california for a real
estate company keller williams selling
homes in the los angeles area he also
dj's there under the name dj raw cb in
between all of this he's raising a son
who looks like a carbon copy of him from
the fresh prince days and on top of
everything his linkedin shows him as the
director of pathways consulting a
corporate finance and i.t recruiting
firm busy guy bagley wasn't asked to
reprise his role in independence day
resurgence he ended up getting the last
laugh though the movie had poor reviews
and underwhelmed at the box office
eric lutz played del cassidy greeting
card proprietor and on-again off-again
boyfriend of the titular caroline in the
city it remains the most high-profile
role of his career after caroline was
cancelled he starred in the short-lived
mary kaden ashley tv series so little
time this marked the second time he
played the father of the twins and has
only worked sparingly since that's in
part because of a health scare that saw
him readjust his life in 2013 lutz
contracted lyme disease and malaria
after a tick bite the recovery lasted
two years during which he lost a lot of
his strength and suffered immense joint
pain during this time to aid with his
recovery he changed his exercise routine
his diet and his priorities he credits
his recovery with making him a more
compassionate person his inability to do
much besides sit also saw him dive into
one of his true passions painting in
2020 he told encourage tv i couldn't
really go to the beach because you have
to stay out of the sun so i would paint
what i wanted to be in he sent the
paintings to a gallery where they sold
well and that became his main focus the
move to painting isn't all that huge a
jump his father was an accomplished
artist and eric himself has always found
comfort in it he told the cheruhou times
in 2020 deep down i've always been an
artist i trusted my ability in painting
more than my ability in acting i never
doubted my ability to sell a painting
fans of danielle brisboa fit by and
large into two camps those who know her
best as a child star and those who know
her best as a musician for those in the
former camp here's what happened to
stephanie mills brisbois played molly an
orphan in the original broadway staging
of annie in 1978 one year after annie
she joined all in the family as
stephanie the niece of archie and edith
she warmed the cold heart of archie
bunker quickly becoming a surrogate
daughter she stuck around through sequel
and spin-off series archie bunker's
place where the audience watched her
grow from a cute kid to a teenager she
acted for a few years after archie
bunker's place went off the air but
largely retired from acting to pursue
her other passion she told the los
angeles times in 2015 i found out that
after doing the tv show i wanted to do
music and more than anything to write
music breeze bois soon met musician greg
alexander and the two formed a
partnership that would last decades she
performed backup vocals on his 1992
album in toxifornication in turn
alexander produced and co-wrote
breesbois solo debut album arrive all
over you the alt rock album was a minor
hit in europe and has a cult following
in america her career as a musician
reached its peak when she and alexander
formed the new radicals the short-lived
rock band best known for hit single you
get what you give alexander ended the
band not long after the single charted
but their creative partnership has
continued alexander produced her second
album and co-wrote the music for the
2013 keira knightley and mark ruffalo
film begin again for this they nabbed an
oscar nomination for best achievement
and music written for motion pictures
for the song lost stars on her own
brisbois has been a successful
songwriter the most notable examples are
the hit singles unwritten and pocketful
of sunshine by natasha bettingfield
rebecca arthur played marianne on
perfect strangers from the second season
to the series finale marianne with her
recognizable curly hair and high-pitched
voice fell in love with balckie married
him and had his child rebecca however
didn't do much in the way of acting
after the series concluded entirely by
choice after marrying and becoming
rebecca arthur golden she told the
perfect stranger's reviewed blog in 2020
that after perfect strangers ended she
was still working but had lost her love
for it she had gotten married and had
her first daughter which needed to
become a higher priority she explained
with acting it was all about me but with
motherhood it was all about them so i
chose them arthur also shared that she
has kept busy with volunteer work and
her clothing business which she's very
vocal about on instagram she added that
she enjoys what she's doing and has no
regrets about moving on from her acting
roles
lauren lane played cece babcock
maxwell's work associate and the
frequent antagonist of nanny fine on the
nanny lane told vice earlier this year
that her specialty was quote evil vixen
roles an apt summary of the cc character
after the nanny got cancelled lane found
her career stifled by two factors first
casting directors only seeing her as
cece and second the fact that she was
pushing 40 in an industry where that's
not a friendly milestone for women she
told vice if you are jessica lange you
can work through your 40s and 50s but
the only way you can is if you have an
academy award that's reality sticks and
stones can break my bones but bad
reviews can kill you
in the early 2000s she auditioned for a
trendy teen soap as a mother she recalls
nailing the audition but realizing the
young white male writers didn't connect
with her this was a turning point
realizing that it wasn't worth
struggling for roles she moved to austin
texas and focused on raising her
daughter while she's barely been on
screen since the nanny she hasn't
exactly left acting behind she's a
tenured theater professor at texas state
university and often performs in plays
across the country lane is also
considering a return to screen acting
she'll be qualified to retire from
academia around 2023 and the time feels
right to her when asked if she'd be
interested in a nanny reboot her answer
is a resounding hell yes i would do it
in 1994 holly folger had a supporting
role in the notable sitcom ellen she
played holly jameson in the first season
a quirky best friend before getting
written out of the show the next year
folger bounced around hollywood for the
next decade or so her most recognizable
role is probably being aunt judy in the
xenon trilogy disney's three-part
television film installment in the late
90s and early 2000s folger hasn't
appeared in a mainstream production
since a 2006 guest spot on the series
without a trace this is because she's
shifted her focus from acting to
tackling beauty standards in 2012 folger
started a web series called speaking of
beauty this spun off into a book titled
speaking of beauty's inner beauty
journal folger says it's a guide to help
women recognize their individuality to
find their beauty not their hair makeup
and body size this in turn led to the
2016 youtube series the hollywood beauty
detective and her current endeavor true
beauty discovery it's a non-profit that
aims to celebrate the diverse beauty
reflected in all of us folger explained
what spurred this career development and
passion for speaking on women's beauty
in an interview with cleveland.com
earlier this year she shared one of the
things that i was always affected by
when i was a kid is i wanted to look
like beautiful women in magazines and on
tv i didn't i had buck teeth braces and
glasses that were so thick that my eyes
looked gigantic it affected my career
because as i became an actress and i
started working it was still the
question of what do you look like i
worked a lot and did wonderful projects
but yet there's always that not enough
feeling this inspired her to dive into
beauty when she got older and had a kid
of her own
phil buckman has had something of a
multi-hyphenate career it's hard to
identify him with any one project he's
been around for a few decades doing
various jobs across diverse realms in
the entertainment industry some may
remember him as vic the zealously loyal
intern from bob patterson jason
alexander's short-lived first shot at a
post-seinfeld career others may just
recognize him from a handful of other
titles including guest appearances on
shows like mom buckman has been around
the block even so most have likely heard
buckman's voice somewhere he spent years
doing voiceover work and he's done
promos for fox shows like the oroville
he also does vocal work in multiple
video games outside of voice acting and
the occasional guest spot buckman is an
accomplished rock bassist he spent a
spell playing bass for industrial rock
band filter and is currently the touring
bassist for fuel he's also a member of
petty cash a hard rocking cover band
made up of touring musicians
stacy keenan spent her youth on three
sitcoms from 1987 to 1990 she starred on
my two dads as nicole the child with the
titular double dad situation from 1990
to 1991 she starred on the long
forgotten tgif sitcom going places she
then got her biggest role yet as dana
foster on step by step she played the
wisecracking young woman for all seven
seasons from 1991 to 1998. unfortunately
she's acted sparsely since then she's
now practicing law she got her jd at
southwestern law school in 2013 spent
the next three years as deputy district
attorney for the riverside d.a and
joined the los angeles da's office in
2016. in 2021 she joined the faculty of
southwestern law school as an adjunct
professor her faculty bio lists her many
legal accomplishments in detail only
adding this brief mention at the end
before beginning her law career
professor sigorski had a career in the
entertainment industry and worked as an
actress on several primetime network
television shows
aaron michael metchick played steven
floyd torkelson the sports-minded
brother of the titular family in the
torkelsons fans of the first season
remember him clearly fans of the second
season never saw him after his character
was retconned out after the show was
retooled he popped up in various other
shows is one of the seemingly endless
child actors the 90s threw at us before
largely vanishing from our screens after
y2k he still makes his living in acting
though but now primarily as an acting
coach aaron's mother robin metchick was
an influential drama teacher in the
arroyo grande area so it's only natural
her son went on to become an actor aaron
metchick's website boasts many success
stories but there's one that looms above
all else in the mid-2000s his mother had
a talented student in her drama class
one she realized had a ton of potential
this happened to be a very very familiar
star named zac efron heard of him robin
metchick set him up with an agent and
aaron became his private acting coach
melinda mullins played hilary booth on
remember when the amc show about the
goings-on of a radio station in the
1930s and 40s hillary an aloof former
stage actress played the female lead in
many of the station's shows the show has
largely left the public imagination
despite the involvement of rupert holmes
and being an early original work of a
now dominant tv channel mullins also
known for playing andrea in dennis the
menace hasn't been seen on screen since
remember when got cancelled in 1998.
after the show's cancellation mullins
was mulling retirement when she met
fellow actor joshua bryant at a film
festival the two fell in love retired
together and went to live in the new
mexico desert they largely keep
themselves and their horses but still
take part in local theater
grizz played by and named after grizz
chapman was the most physically imposing
of tracy's entourage in 30 rock and the
most sensitive 30 rock was chapman's
first credited acting role on screen and
remains his most prominent he's appeared
in a couple dozen shows and movies since
almost always in a bouncer or bodyguard
type role besides the possibility of
typecasting and limited roles for anyone
over seven feet tall chapman hasn't had
too many roles lately because he has
other business endeavors chapman co-owns
bronx-based comic shop the lair and
frequents comic cons as both a vendor
and a fan he also hosts the underdog
podcast where he interviews musicians
actors and various other personalities
guests include jon hamm adam richman and
former 30 rock co-star scott adsit
chapman also has a cameo account so if
you miss seeing him on your screen you
can pay him 30 and he'll address you
personally to get your fix you're the
best
john lutz played j.d lutz the biggest
loser in the room of losers that was the
tgs writing staff on 30 rock a huge dork
despised by everyone around him lutz was
often a victim of the pranksman and the
source of liz and jack's frequent ire
the real lutz is far more liked but he
does use unpopular dweeb as part of his
comic persona outside mapleworth murders
a show he co-wrote and starred in for
quibby he hasn't been in much sense but
fans of late night television have still
seen him fairly often post 30 rock lutz
was always more of a writer than an
actor and as such returned to that world
after 30 rock rapped he almost
immediately joined the inaugural writing
staff of late night with seth meyers and
remains there to this day he also plays
versions of himself like in a late night
bit where he is sent a green screen for
zoom but instead uses a picture of his
own living room one of his most common
recurring bits is the leave him alone
guy an audience member who sticks up for
the oft despicable public figures myers
mocks and offers himself as an
alternative target
leave him alone
layla kenzel played fran devaneau the
90s sitcom mandated neurotic best friend
on mad about you proximity to helen hunt
and paul reiser on a popular sitcom
should have guaranteed something of a
career after the series wrapped but show
business in that era wasn't suited for
her she told the new york post in 2007 i
was 37 and the idea of having to parade
myself in front of 27 year old
executives began to feel a bit silly i
wanted to be treated like a grown-up and
so she changed careers kenzel did the
odd guest spot here and there all while
attending antioch university she
graduated with a master's in psychology
in 2002 and now works as a therapist in
los angeles of course her old show is
still in syndication which can cause
issues she shared if patients recognize
me right away it takes some time to
figure out who they're meeting me or
fran she is so very involved in her
practice that kenzel didn't even return
for the mad about you revival in 2019
johnny castle played dr doug murphy on
scrubs playing a fatally inept doctor
turned successful pathologist proved
somewhat prescient about his personal
life specifically the part about a
career change after scrubs wrapped he
appeared on a half dozen episodes of the
patrick swayze vehicle the beast before
retiring from acting he hasn't had
another screen credit since because he's
gone into law not long after leaving the
beast castle enrolled at the university
of iowa college of law starting around
2010 when he was a 2l he clerked at the
u.s attorney's office for the northern
district of iowa he later spent time
practicing law at various firms and
companies before co-founding acorn
finance where he serves as vp of
business development in 2019 castle told
the chicago tribune law was always the
end goal when scrubs was winding down we
had reached a point where we wanted to
have kids and it seemed like the right
time for the exit strategy when asked if
he ever saw himself acting again he said
that if so it wouldn't be immediately
but eventually there's a possibility he
spent some time on the victory gardens
theatre board of directors never fully
leaving show business behind check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite sitcom stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]